PRESENTER: Good afternoon.
I have the pleasure
and privilege and honor
of welcoming to the Google
campus Dada Nabhaniilananda,
also known as the monk dude.
Dada is a meditation
teacher, a yoga monk, author,
singer songwriter,
and speaker who
is originally from
New Zealand and was
has ordained as a
monk in India in 1979.
And if you have
the image of a monk
as being somebody
being very reclusive
and retreating off to
a monastic environment,
then perish the thought.
Because since then, he
has traveled, spoken,
and performed in 40
different countries,
including once in Brazil
in front of the Dalai Lama
and 10,000 people
in the audience.
In fact, I myself had
the distinct pleasure
of running into Dada once
at Yoshi's Jazz Club, where
we both had gone to
listen to [INAUDIBLE].
And I was intrigued.
Who is this person in
orange with the turban?
I need to talk to
him and find out.
And it turned out he was one
of the most interesting people
I've ever met.
Dada has produced
eight musical album.
He's the author of the
book meditation book
"Close Your Eyes,
Open Your Mind,"
which has been translated
into 10 different languages.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: Yep.
Just 10, just last
week, Vietnamese.
PRESENTER: Vietnamese
being the latest.
He also teaches a
course on meditation
and how it unlocks creativity
at the University of Berkeley
and speaks on this topic
to several corporations
all over the world.
I'm delighted, once again, to
welcome to the Google campus
singer songwriter, performer,
author, and yoga monk
and meditation teacher,
Dada Nabhaniilananda,
also known as the monk dude.
[APPLAUSE]
DADA NABHANIILANADA: Thanks
so much, [INAUDIBLE],
and thanks very much for
inviting me back to Google.
Because I was here last year.
Who was at my talk
here last year?
A couple of you were.
OK, good.
Because I've got to tell
you, I discovered since then
that everything I told
you then was wrong.
No, I'm just kidding.
But at least must
of you weren't here,
so I can reuse some of my
Google jokes from them.
So I'm going to be speaking
to you about meditation
and the idea of the
enlightened leader,
and how meditation can help you
to develop love, creativity,
and wisdom.
At the beginning
of last year, I was
speaking at a
corporate conference,
and at the end of
the presentation,
we had a short meditation
and chanting session.
And just after, one of the
directors of the company
came up to me and thanked
me and said, I want to say,
that was the first time--
just that short meditation
was the first time I
felt peace in months.
And it really struck me.
Because I thought, wow,
this is really serious
that there's so many people
in the corporate community who
are silently suffering.
And what I've got to offer is
more valuable than I realized,
because I've taken
it for granted.
I've just taught them
something, a short meditation.
I've done 1,000 times.
It's no big deal for me.
But for her, it was
really important,
and perhaps for many others.
If you develop a regular
meditation practice,
it can remove most
of your suffering
if you experience anything like
that from stress and anxiety
and the related
kind of problems.
How many of you
feel that you suffer
from some kind of stress?
It's pretty much universal.
Believe it or not, I do,
too, but not very much
compared to what I might do
if I didn't use this practice
to help me.
But you all probably
knew that already.
Everybody knows that meditation
relieves stress-- probably
everyone at Google, at
least, because you've
got a whole big
meditation program here.
It's called Search
Inside Yourself.
I believe it's free on campus.
It started in Google, and it's
gone out to other companies.
You also have somebody
whose job, full time,
is to make sure that people
that go to the program actually
practice.
Because they discover
that lots of people
went through the training that
then didn't keep the habit.
So that's his job, and Google
is paying him to do that.
So it's seen as a
priority by somebody
somewhere in this company.
But most of you
probably already knew
that meditation relieves stress.
But what I'm really
interested in
is how meditation does
way more than that.
There are a whole
lot of other benefits
from meditation that I
actually find more exciting.
I'm going to talk about
three of them today.
And that is how it can develop
love, creativity, and wisdom,
and how it can help you to
improve your relationships.
That's what love does.
How wisdom, as you
develop it, can help
you make much clearer
decisions, how creativity
can make you more innovative.
And we're going to use the
ancient science of yoga.
We're going to draw on
that to get to that result.
And yoga is a very
misunderstood word these days.
Most people think
of it immediately
as some kind of exercise
station that young ladies
go to because they want
to be young forever.
That's just one of
the bits of yoga.
There's a system
called asthanga yoga.
Yoga has eight limbs,
like my friend here.
That's in the Sanskrit.
So astungas means postures.
That's the yoga postures.
The first limb of
yoga is called Yama,
and it roughly translates
as don't be evil.
That rings a bell.
Is that familiar
to anybody here?
Your company was founded on
the first principle of yoga.
So what is yoga, really?
If it's not just
these exercises,
it's all these other things.
It's a whole lifestyle.
It's a philosophy.
It's a value system, and a set
of not just physical exercises,
but mental exercises--
concentration
exercises, breathing, and
different meditation techniques
all designed to develop
your body, mind,
and spirit in harmony.
So when I talk about yoga, I
mean the whole big yoga, not
just the physical exercises.
The other thing I want to clear
up which might be misunderstood
sometimes is that I'm not
actually a religious fanatic.
You could be
forgiven for thinking
that, because I'm dressed like
maybe I'm a religious fanatic.
But this is something
I like to address
at the beginning of
my presentations.
Because sometimes
somebody will come up
to me at the end of a constant
or a talk or something
and they'll ask me shyly, why
are you dressed like that?
And I realize that
they haven't been
able to think of anything
else the whole time.
They didn't listen
to a word I said.
So better that I answer
this at the beginning.
And it's very simple.
I'm from New Zealand, and
everybody in New Zealand
dresses like this.
OK, that's not completely true.
There are three
other monks like me
from New Zealand, so at least
four of us out of four million.
This is the traditional
color-- orange or saffron
is the traditional color
worn by monks and nuns
from oriental traditions,
like Buddhism and Jainism
Hinduism and yoga.
And it symbolizes
self-sacrifice.
And the turban comes
in handy in case
a real religious
fanatic throws something
at me to protect my head.
So that's a little bit about
why I'm dressed like this.
Leadership.
Why am I even
interested in the idea
of more enlightened leaders?
It's really simple.
Leaders have power.
The have influence.
They act as role models.
And humanity is in a situation
where we're facing the greatest
number of incredibly
complex problems
that we've ever
faced in history.
And I think right now, we could
do with some really, really
good leadership.
So I want to do whatever
I can to enhance that.
But being an enlightened leader
is more than just a fancy title
like head beagle.
Snoopy was once elected
the head beagle,
and he found it a lot
of responsibility.
And he said, I have to
make a lot of decisions.
Today, I made 147 decisions.
All of them were wrong.
So if Snoopy is not our
ideal leader, who is?
Do you have some
people that you look up
to that you think embody
the kind of qualities
that you look for in leadership?
Let's have some examples.
It might be somebody
in your personal life.
It might be your mother.
My mom was the head of
our family, no question.
Or it might be somebody
prominent-- a famous comedian.
I don't know.
So tell us some
figures in your life,
somebody in your life who's
inspired you that you feel
has played that role for you.
AUDIENCE: Both my parents.
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
Your parents.
Great.
And what qualities, what
particular quality do you
think they embodied?
AUDIENCE: To be firm
about your desires
without being a jerk about it.
[INAUDIBLE] compromising
with people around you.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: OK, cool.
Let's have some other ones.
AUDIENCE: A number
of teachers I've had.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: Teachers
in school or college here.
Cool.
And the qualities?
I'm looking for the qualities.
Try to give us one word,
one-word definitions.
AUDIENCE: Authenticity.
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
Authenticity.
Fantastic.
I was always a big
fan of Nelson Mandela.
And I would say if I had
to choose one word that he
embodied forgiveness.
And that's a huge inspiration
to me and to the world.
Some others?
AUDIENCE: Gandhi.
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
Mahatma Gandhi.
And what does he embody?
AUDIENCE: One word is hard.
Unconditional love.
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
AUDIENCE: A guy I worked
with four years ago here,
Eric Schmidt.
Not a single word, but a
phrase-- smart and balanced.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: OK.
Not coffee.
AUDIENCE: No.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: OK.
Cool.
So those kind of
qualities-- and there
are a whole lot
more-- that's what
I've been trying to develop
consciously since I was 19.
And that was way back somewhere
in the Pleistocene Era
as far as I can remember.
So how did I get into this?
How did I start off
doing meditation?
If you had told me
when I was about 12--
which was just after I became
an atheist-- that I'd end up
being a monk, I would have said
you'd lost your last marble.
Because I had a very
different ambition.
I wanted to be a wizard.
I wanted to be wise
and strong and kind,
like Gandalf, who defeated the
evil dark lord of the ring.
You may detect a
flaw in this plan.
It took a little while
for me to figure it out.
I finally realized that
wizards don't exist.
So I had to adopt a more
realistic life goal.
I like playing music.
So I thought, why don't
I become a rock star?
But when I was 19,
I hadn't experience
that changed everything.
It was a kind epiphany, you
could say-- a very powerful
spiritual experience.
Imagine all the love in
the universe condensed
into a single moment floating
before you like the sun,
so real that the rest of
your life seems like a dream.
And in that moment, I realized
that the purpose of existence
is to become one with the
source of love within us.
And I felt inspired to walk
the spiritual path as a Yogi
and master my mind
through meditation,
and hopefully to
become a teacher
and help other people find
the path to happiness.
I'd finally found a life purpose
that actually made sense.
So I left my university,
and I left my country,
and I went to India.
And there, I studied
the intuitive science
of tantra yoga and the
ancient wisdom of the mystics.
And I studied under
a great master.
That was a long time ago.
But you don't have to
become a monk like me
in order to get the
benefits of meditation.
I have a friend--
his name is Mike.
I met him a few years ago.
And Mike is a manager
of big projects.
He was running a
$100 million project,
and he was under
a lot of pressure.
He would get up at the crack
of dawn and jump into his car
and drive it through the
traffic like a weapon,
and yelling on the
phone at contractors.
He's get to work and
continue his day like that.
The stress was really
telling on him.
He came to a workshop of mine
where he learned meditation
and a chanting technique.
Before he left, somebody
suggested to him,
why don't you get one
of these chanting CDs
so you can play it in your car?
I think there must have
been a passenger in his car
at some point.
They wanted him to slow down.
He said, no.
My CD player in
my car is broken.
There's been a Beatles CD stuck
in there for three months,
and I haven't
bothered to fix it.
But at the last minute,
he thought, oh, I'll
get the CD anyway.
He comes down to his
car, opens the door,
and the Beatles
CD has popped out.
So he took that as a sign.
So he started listening to
this chanting in his car.
And instead of
yelling on the phone
and feeling like
he's at war, he was
relaxed when he got to work.
And he was nicer to people, he
got along with people better,
and he laughed more often.
And then he started
meditating in his office
before he would go home.
And his workmates would comment
that his office felt peaceful.
And then he had created this
sentry in his office space.
And as he changed, his
surroundings changed as well.
So what did love, creativity,
and wisdom do for Mike?
Through being more
creative, he was
able to innovate in the
ways that he did things.
Through developing
more clarity in wisdom,
he was able to make
much better decisions,
because he wasn't so emotional.
And when he developed more
feeling of love and connection,
all his relationships improved.
And this didn't do too
badly for his career.
Right now, he's helping
to build the $4.5 billion
Apple Spaceship in Cupertino.
Creativity.
Creativity is a kind of power.
With creativity, we've learned
to manipulate our environment,
and we've taken over the world.
We've built all kind of
cultures and civilizations.
Every city and ship and
corporation like Google
and piece of music and
book-- and not to neglect
the 357 different
types of toothpaste--
started with an idea.
Ideas are powerful.
Creativity has enabled us
to take over the world.
And that's why when IBM
conducted a very extensive
study in 2013 trying to
find out what qualities are
organizations looking
for in future leaders,
they found that the number one
quality they were looking for
was creativity.
So how do we tap
into our creativity?
Where does creativity come from?
Would you like to know
if you are creative?
Who thinks they are creative?
Some of you.
I have actually
developed a test.
This is the only 100%
effective psychological test
in the world.
It's called the Monk
Dude's Famous Creativity
Test, modestly named by myself.
And it requires you to stand
up and answer one question.
You don't even need to speak.
You get to answer
it with your bodies.
I have one question
for you, and that
is who amongst you was not
at some point in your life
a child?
If you were never a
child, remain standing.
If you were, you can sit down.
I just did this
exercise in Mexico,
and somebody remained standing.
I thought, every room has one.
I always tell him to remain
standing in the back corner.
You're all too polite.
All children are creative.
They love to play.
Creativity comes out
of that kind of mode.
So our inner child
is still there.
But as we grow older, we
develop this other side,
the critical adult.
And the critical adult
tends to suppress
the creative child.
That's why Disney-- they're
not allowed in the same room.
They literally have separate
rooms for creative thinking.
Disney movie studios,
they have separate rooms
for creative thinking
and critical thinking.
And this was Walt
Disney's own policy,
because he understood that these
two cannot operate at the same
time.
So how do we connect to
that inner creative child
we all have?
I just proved it to you.
I learned the answer to this
when I started meditating.
And I didn't expect it.
I started meditating because
I wanted to become enlightened
or something grand like that.
But one of the first
things I noticed
was that suddenly, I started
getting all these ideas
for my music and my poetry.
That's what I was into.
And it was like I had
turned on this tap of ideas
somewhere inside.
And I remember sitting--
and I was learning a piece
by Beethoven.
It was his first piano
sonnata-- the last seven
chords of the first movement,
for those who are interested.
And it seemed so beautiful.
And I was transported.
And I felt for a
moment, really, I
felt that I was
Beethoven at the moment
that he wrote this music.
And I was feeling
what he was feeling.
It was extraordinary.
And I thought, this
meditation is doing something
really different to me.
I don't know.
I didn't expect this.
What I learned very
soon afterwards
was that the Yogis who
developed these practices,
they understood.
They had figured
this out ages ago.
They had a whole
map of the mind,
and which bit is creative,
and how you tap into it,
what technique you
use to get to this.
And they'd developed a
system for developing,
amongst other things, love,
creativity, and wisdom.
And it's all related to
the different Chakras,
but I'm not going to
talk about that today.
That's grade three.
So the middle one, creativity.
So the yogis divide the
mind into five layers.
The first two, you're probably
familiar with-- the idea
of conscious mind and
subconscious mind.
It's not exactly
parallel to this system,
but it's very similar.
And then they divide
this third layer,
which is lumped together
in Western psychology
into the unconscious.
They divide that into
three layers of intuition.
And the first of
those is creativity,
and we can tap into that
with a particular meditation
technique.
And that's what I discovered.
It's hard to find very good
research of creativity.
It's really easy
to find research
on stress related to meditation,
but creativity is much harder
to measure.
But [INAUDIBLE]
University in Germany,
a group of cognitive
psychologists
came up with this
result. They said
that certain
meditation techniques
can promote creative thinking.
The advantages of particular
types of meditation
extend much further
than simply relaxation,
which is what I've been
telling people for years.
I was so happy to find this.
That's what I thought
when I saw this study.
So creativity is power.
It gives us power.
But not all the things
that we have created
are as beautiful as
a Beethoven sonata.
We've also created
terrible weapons,
oppressive forms of government,
exploitative systems
of economics, toxic
chemicals, the Spice Girls.
Terrible outcomes have come
from the creative mind, which
is why it's so important
for an enlightened leader
also to cultivate wisdom.
A few years ago,
I met a young man.
He impressed me very much.
It was at a meditation
retreat, and he was meditating.
And his mother showed me an
essay he wrote for his school.
It was called "30
Things I Believe."
I'll read you part of it.
I believe life is good.
I believe God is in everything.
I believe we are all equal.
I believe that when I
meditate, I feel peaceful.
I believe we should be generous.
I believe kids should
respect their parents.
Any parents here?
You agree with him?
I believe people
should go outside more.
I believe we should help the
Arctic and rainforest animals.
I believe God is
in good and in bad.
I believe in magic.
I believe people
should not give up.
I believe love is everywhere.
I believe we live
best in community.
I believe we can protect
people in danger.
I believe we should
help the poor.
I believe it's OK to
die, but not to kill.
I believe war should stop.
I believe we can make peace.
When Tarak MacLean wrote
this, he was six years old.
I should tell you,
he's a teenager now.
He has blue hair.
He's not as cute
as this anymore.
But this blew my mind,
and a lot of other people.
He went on NPR and so forth.
You don't need a
Ph.D. to have wisdom.
Many of us confuse knowledge,
information with wisdom.
But they are very
different things.
In fact-- well, any of you
read "Lord of The Rings?"
You remember Saruman?
He made some very,
very bad decisions.
Very smart guy.
And Gandalf called
him a wise fool.
I thought that was pretty cool.
There's piece of
research being done
at Toronto University
where they were
trying to correlate intelligence
with rational, balanced
decisions.
And the result that they found
was that there's no connection.
The harsh truth is that
greater intelligence does not
equate to wiser decisions.
So I know you're all-- a
lot of people in Google
have done a lot of work
on their education,
a lot of smart people.
But this doesn't necessarily
mean you make better decisions.
Joseph Stalin was probably
a pretty smart guy.
I think you get the point.
So good decisions
really come out
of a combination of
rationality and intuition.
Intuition is a different
kind of function from several
of these higher levels of mind.
And if we just develop
our intellect and reason
and think that's going to
solve all our problems,
you're dreaming.
We need these subtler faculties.
And many great thinkers have
pointed this out-- Einstein
for sure.
Steve Jobs always
talked about this.
There's this lovely quote from
this writer-- this is actually
a real photograph of a Google
employee, of their brain,
the actual contents of
somebody working here.
I'm not allowed to say who it
is, but they're in this room.
It could be you.
So what are you
doing with your mind?
We're all intelligent.
We've got a lot of stuff
going on, thinking.
But what are we thinking
about, actually?
I think that a great
majority of it--
going by my own mind, the
great proportion of it is junk.
And for most people, it
would be huge benefit
to learn to think less.
Keep the quality ones.
I just keep the
Star Wars previews
and get rid of the rest.
Intuition.
If you slow your
mind down to get you
intuition back-- you
get your intuition back
when you make space for it,
when you stop the chattering
of the rational mind.
So once again,
these two functions
are mutually exclusive.
And actually, research
into intuitive insights
amongst indigenous tribes has
revealed that they generally
are much more intuitive than
city dwellers and educated
intellectuals.
We're out of balance, and we've
lost something in that process.
So wisdom comes out
of a nice combination
of rationality and intuition.
Love.
Creativity has enabled
us to conquer the world,
but only love can
conquer your heart.
I'm not talking
about romantic love.
I'm talking about something
much bigger and certainly
more dependable than that.
I'm talking about the
invisible glue that
creates friendships and
families and communities,
the sense of
connection that enables
us to look at a stranger and
see ourselves in their eyes
or inspires a little
girl to share her ice
cream with a puppy.
Edgar Mitchell was
an Apollo astronaut.
When he was coming
back from the moon,
he had an extraordinary
experience, a euphoric insight.
And he said this.
You develop an instant global
consciousness, a people
orientation, an
intense dissatisfaction
with the state of the
world and a compulsion
to do something about it.
From out there on the moon,
international politics
looked so petty.
You want to grab a politician
by the scruff of the neck
and drag him a quarter
of a million miles out
and say, look at that,
you son of a bitch.
My kind of astronaut.
I love this guy.
Oh.
I just gave the game away.
Oh, dear.
To develop this
sense of connection,
and this sense of community,
and this sense of friendship,
and really feeling what
other people feel--
the most effective way
to do that-- well, you
might think I'm going to say
meditation if I hadn't already
given you the clue.
But actually, what I
found in my experience
is most effective in
doing this is music.
And that's why in our
practice we use music
to lead into meditation.
Music is the
language of emotion.
If you get back from work,
and you're kind of tired,
and you're a bit down, you
put on your favorite piece
of music, what happens?
It's an instant mood change.
It takes seconds.
It's very powerful.
It resonates with our nervous
system, and our Chakras,
and the whole body and mind.
So before meditating--
which we're
going to do in a
little while-- we
use music to put
you in the mood,
and then it's much
easier to concentrate.
If you try and go
straight from work mode--
you've got to be serious,
you've got to make money--
and then you go to suddenly
be peaceful and not
be thinking too much,
it's very difficult
to make that transition
without something
to shift you into the right
kind of emotional background.
And that's what music does.
So I use music as a
lead-in to meditation.
And you'll find it in so many
different spiritual traditions,
also.
Just about every
spiritual tradition
uses music for the same reason.
So how does meditation work?
A couple of questions
I want to ask you.
First thing-- who thinks
that to meditate you
have to stop thinking?
Maybe.
This is often confusing.
The end result of
meditation might be a state
where you're not thinking.
But to get there, it's
very hard to get there
by trying to stop think.
It's pretty much impossible.
Because the mind is
a thinking machine.
It's designed to think.
And you have to lead it by
a more roundabout route.
So I would say the
meditation, you get there
by concentrating,
learning to concentrate
on at least one thought
or single flow of thoughts
rather than wandering
all over the place,
and that leads you to
a state of deep peace.
So I think that's
a misconception.
So I think that
meditation means equal
stopping thinking--
the practice.
Maybe the end result,
but not the practice.
Second question.
Who thinks that meditation is
the same thing as mindfulness?
None of you.
Because you know I'm going to
say that's not true, right,
and you don't want
to get it wrong.
A lot of people actually
do think meditation is
the same thing as mindfulness.
But nobody in this
room, clearly,
because you're all way
too smart for that.
Because meditation is
more than mindfulness.
Mindfulness is a
part of meditation.
It's kind of step one, or
it might be step three.
But it's a subset.
So just to give you a very--
this is a very eloquent man.
I think you know who
that is-- Jim Carrey.
So he's speaking about
an experience that
is, I would say, beyond
mindfulness, just
so you get it really clear.
JIM CARREY: A few months
ago, I understood suddenly
how thought was just
an illusory thing,
and how thought is
responsible for, if not all,
most of the suffering
we experience.
And then I suddenly felt like
I was looking at these thoughts
from another perspective.
And I wondered, who is it
that's aware that I'm thinking?
And suddenly, I was thrown into
this expensive, amazing feeling
of freedom from myself,
from my problems.
I saw that I was
bigger than what I do.
I was bigger than my body.
I was everything and everyone.
I was no longer a
fragment of the universe.
I was the universe.
And ever since that day, I've
been trying to get back there.
It comes and it goes.
It's like riding a wave.
Sometimes I'm on.
Sometimes I'm off.
But at least I know
where I want to go.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: I could
not have put it better myself.
So we lost a little
time at the beginning,
because we started late.
So I want to skip
forward and actually
get to where we're
going to meditate.
OK.
I'm going to run
through this fast.
Neuroplasticity.
You know what
neural pathways are?
When you think,
your brain changes.
If you keep thinking
in a particular way,
you create neural pathways.
Our thinking habits
change our physical brain,
and it changes our personality.
We used to think
that the brain was
a static physiological
organ, but that understanding
has changed completely.
And thinking, it's a
little bit like water.
It doesn't have a
particular form.
It's kind of soft.
But that's very deceptive.
It can be very powerful.
If water keeps running in
a stream for a long time,
this can become this.
So keep thinking happy thoughts,
and you'll be happier person.
If you keep thinking
angry thoughts,
you'll become an angry person.
It's very reassuring to
me that this new discovery
of neuroplasticity has
confirmed something that Yogis
have known for 7,000 years.
Thought is extremely
powerful, especially
repetitive,
concentrated thought.
And that's one of the
secrets of meditation,
that type of concentration.
It changes your brain.
It changes you over time.
To do that, we use
something called a mantra.
Wizards use magic words,
Yogis use mantras.
So a mantra is a, in this
case, a Sanskrit word of power.
And it's repeated or
sung, and it really
helps to bring us into
that meditative state using
the sound and also the meaning
behind the mantra, the power
of positive thinking
which is demonstrated
in neuroplasticity.
So the mantra we are going
to use has three words,
and we're going to
put to music to it.
And it means love is
the essence of all.
It's a very positive idea.
So to meditate-- I want
you all to sit straight.
Feet flat on the floor, please.
Hands cupped in your
lap, thumbs together.
Hopefully, this
is going to work.
So first, let's get
the mantra straight.
Can we get the mantra back?
Thank you.
I want you to
pronounce it with me.
So it's pronounced baba.
AUDIENCE: Baba.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: Nam.
AUDIENCE: Nam.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: Kevalam.
AUDIENCE: Kevalam.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: And all
together, baba nam kevalam.
Very good.
So as I said, that means love
is the essence of everything,
essentially.
So you're welcome to
sing with me if you want.
And I'll guide you through a
very short, silent meditation.
And just keep your eyes closed.
And breathe through your
nose if you can comfortably.
And let the mantra and the
music continue silently
as though you're hearing it,
as though your inner voice were
singing to you-- singing
to you and reminding you
that within you is a place
of perfect peace and love
and harmony.
And it's always there.
And you can return to
it if you pay attention.
So just let the music and the
mantra continue in your mind
by itself.
Let that be your focus
for a couple of minutes
of silence now.
I've seen this kind of practice
and this kind of lifestyle
transform from
really somebody who
maybe had a lot of
problems, really
didn't know what
they wanted to do,
into somebody who's
very centered, very open
hearted, much more connected
to their source of wisdom
and creativity and love.
And I think that with
this kind of practice,
we can create a new kind
of corporate culture
where everybody
understands that health
and well being have no price,
that people matter more
than things, and
that the solution
to most of our problems is
really right inside of us.
There's something in
yoga called a Mudra.
A Mudra is something
that connects
the mind and body with meaning.
It's a language of the body.
This idea can be
represented with the hands.
The hands are creative.
We've created all
kinds of things.
We build things.
We write, we play the
piano, we use computers.
Hands are creative.
They're amazing
creative instruments.
But without your head, they
wouldn't know what to do.
So your head is like this.
And your mind, if it doesn't
get guidance from your heart,
it doesn't always
make the best choices.
So there's a Mudra in yoga
call the Namaskar Mudra,
and it goes like this.
The hands, the
head, and the heart.
Let's all do that.
Then you'll remember it.
Muscle memory.
So the hands are creative,
the mind can produce wisdom,
and the heart is what
connects us to everyone else.
So thank you all very much.
That's called a Namaskar Mudra.
We've got a little
time for questions.
And I can also give
you a little bit
of information about where you
can learn more if you'd like.
But let's see if you
have any questions.
Yeah.
Do we have a mic?
You can use the guitar mic.
Just pretend you're a guitar.
It'll be fine.
AUDIENCE: So actually,
I have two questions.
The first one was--
earlier on, there
was a reference to research
that certain kinds of meditation
can improve creativity.
And I was wondering
if that meant
certain kinds of
meditation are particularly
good for creativity,
other kinds of meditation
may be good at other things.
Is that what was meant by that?
And in that case, what
kinds of meditation
are particularly good
at bringing about--
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
The practice
in Asthanga yoga, this
eight-limbed yoga that
helps to develop
the level of mind
that creativity arises
from, is called Pratyahara,
it means sense withdrawal.
There are various techniques
of sense withdrawal,
but effectively it means
to withdraw your attention
from the world and
focus your mind inward.
And that's usually done
through visualization.
AUDIENCE: The second question
is about-- so being aware of how
as one thinks, so one becomes.
And sometimes, we're
in situations where
there are affairs that come up.
I'm in trouble.
I need to perform
better at work.
And my mind is thinking,
how am I going to do this?
And if I lose my job, then
I'm going to lose this,
and we can't afford
to pay for that.
And in the mind-- you're
trying to sleep at night,
and the mind just keeps
going on and creating this.
And I know-- yes, these
thoughts are not helpful.
These thoughts will
create more fear.
I don't want them.
But I don't remember choosing
to have these thoughts.
They just keep
coming by themselves.
And they're very, very
stubborn, these ones
that are attached
to these deep fears.
And I was wondering, do you
have any specific recommendation
for when you find yourself
in that kind of situation?
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
Well, there are
some things that can help
when the problem pops up.
But meditation is more
effective as a preventative.
So what I would say is that
if you practice meditation--
and actually,
specifically spiritual
chanting-- you tend to-- this
really addresses anxiety.
You tend to let go of
that fear-based anxiety
when you've been
practicing for a while.
So on the spur of the moment,
I don't have a magic bullet
to come along and
say, this is going
to stop you being anxious.
But if you do these
practices regularly,
you're probably not
going to get like that.
While you're
wondering about that,
I might tell you
what you can do next.
Read my book.
Yes, everybody
should read my book.
It's available in 10
languages, including
Vietnamese and Norwegian
and blah, blah, blah.
Lots of people think it's
good book, not just me.
The other thing is
if you want to get
a recording of this
kind of chanting
and a guided meditation,
you can give me your email
or just text it to
me at that number,
and I'll send you a link.
Or you can download a
couple of sunrise and sunset
meditations, which a lot
of people really like.
And the music is great,
I have to tell you.
It was recorded with another
musician friend of mine
who's a fabulous guitarist.
I'll also send you the
slide set if you want
to get some of the pictures.
Everybody wants the picture of
the little girl with the puppy
feeding the ice cream.
What other stuff?
What else do I do?
You can just write to me if
you've got any questions.
If you want to learn more,
I do one-to-one coaching.
I teach workshops and
retreats and stuff like that.
So that's all available.
And that's my website,
The Monk Dude Speaks.
That's my new
corporate website which
was very beautifully
put together by Emily.
Thank you.
Emily is also
collecting testimonials
if any if you would
like to say something
about what you got out
of this so we can use
that to inspire other
people to maybe come
to programs like this.
So that's going to be
happening straight afterwards.
I think that's everything I'm
going to tell you unless we've
got any other questions.
AUDIENCE: How do you
lead the horse to water?
I know some people
that benefit from it,
and you tell them about
the possibilities, yet--
DADA NABHANIILANADA: I
know 7 billion people
who could benefit from it.
There's a very good book
called "10% Happier."
Anybody read it?
There was a guy who's super
skeptic, this ABC journalist,
Dan-- what's his name?
AUDIENCE: Harris.
DADA NABHANIILANADA:
Dan Harris, thank you.
So Dan Harris, he's
a brilliant writer.
He's a nationally famous
journalists, so he'd better be.
So he was super skeptical,
tremendously resistant.
But what convinced
him was the science.
Science is the
religion of the day.
The research proves that
meditation helps you.
People that do it have
known that for 7,000 years.
But nowadays, we
only believe it if we
can see it in a laboratory
and all those figures.
So we have those figures
now demonstrating
a lot of the benefits.
The more subtle benefits
that I'm personally
most interested in are harder
to prove, as I indicated.
And creativity is just
the beginning of that.
But the more tangible
benefits, the physiological
stress-related benefits,
there's no doubt.
That's one way to do it.
Get them to read
Dan Harris' book.
That's pretty convincing.
Or just watch his video.
He's got a really
need four-minute video
you can find on
YouTube, which is
a brilliant exposition on
the benefits of meditation
in four minutes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DADA NABHANIILANADA: OK.
Thank you all very much.
I think that's it.
[APPLAUSE]